c'est un point d'accord tu vois tu vois
que mon terrain d'un beau petit après
lyon à l'essor est ce que tu es prêt je
suis prêt donc à la tenue de sport
thomas très bien je décline jour bas
mais le
belge a tu joues pas mal vote non à
gbagbo une faute pas les antilles est
alors
passé là-bas l'entraînement tu attends
ben c'est comme moi j'ai pas moi j'ai
pas de faute ah bah tant pis pour toi
c'est une le monde d'accord allez vas-y
c'est bien sa faute là est bonne mais
non mais je n'ai pas pu savourer son
football
alors 100 euros pour l'association allez
vas-y bon sens ottrott pour moi le
sourire oh tu vas tu attends tu veux
faire quitte ou double nous il ya 200
euros pour l'association est ce que tu
veux parler toi 100 euros ouais bien sûr
et 300 euros c'est pourquoi ce nom pour
toi la marche
contre bonds de son robot associations
c'est n'importe quoi cette séquence on
peut avoir le champion la met soi disant
qu'ils jouaient super bon
alors on va faire un autre jeux en fait
c'est à chaque fois que je gagne un
point c'est 100 euros pour l'association
ces mini basket chinois a pas donné
beaucoup n'osent ait
à les séries
mais elle lui il était lui ils étaient
400 cadres allait frôler une balle et
rannée amené -
soit il joue bien ce qu'ils jouent bien
moi si je viens jouer alors
allez sauront aller à l'essai parti doit
ça fait 200 merci à toi prenez une
balade en devenir les enfants l'amour
allez allez allez allez allez monsieur
na
waie salem sun nah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'épreuve madame vous le cul c'est pas
possible regarde moi tu là à l'aiguillé
l'hymne des gouttes
lui mais dans la tête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
k.traore
amenez moi quelqu'un allait à 10 go mais
si tu fais toi
alors commandé à portier
500 euros merci non urgentes un homme a
non salées merci ont choisi merci ça
tourne hommes et ipad de louise
bombardier basée au toit c'est bien je
mets toi
qui as i say say jamais joué de ma vie
pro c'est pas grave tu veux non mais non
bon bah on va il est où là parce qu'on
attend le champion l'an
on attend il est arrivé au bo face à la
mer six cents
600 mais les mecs cette séquence est
folle
bon débarras ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
sachez que maintenant et je ne rigole
pas si vous gagnez un point c'est 50
euros pour vous de plus à l'est sur
votre paye à la fin du mois
50 balles tu leur mets en taule
samba samba à dallas vous me dites à
caen dijon je les remettrai toujours en
jeu
[Applaudissements]
sa cavale casta dit tu sais que tu en as
besoin [ __ ] il m'a tuer
50 mangasie qu'est ce tu fais en double
bien sûr est sûre pas comme ça
[Applaudissements]
ça dégage
est en face à rieumes à contrôler et que
tu peux pas jurer que cette tenue du
combat tu sors tu sors tu me
tues des gouttes tout le monde je vais
jouer vraiment la tête à l'heure c'était
une blague derrière la balle c'est
derrière la bande à la ligne homme à
l'égo
et oui il ya un large et au stress avis
ça doit pas les ondes des conseils alors
qu'elle sait pas jouer
franc c'est beau c'est l'élégance et
élégant
c'est n'importe quoi
c'est bon on attend on attend quelqu'un
vas-y rêver
surtout que
50 bah
non merci monsieur vous êtes trop laid
merci à la santé comme ça il est bon
mais dis moi et tu étais pas et castaldi
tu es ce que tu veux le faire est ce que
vous les cas si vous allez en choisir un
qui va vous représentez maintenant
c'est très simple à gérer va bouger la
jambe cassée non mais les gars c'est
très simple vous fournissez le meilleur
d'entre vous aussi d'ailleurs
sachez qu'on va faire cinq points en
cinq points si vous gagnez
je rajoute 100 euros à tous à votre
salaire oh là là on prend demain si vous
perdez c'est bon si vous perdez vous
perdez chacun 20 euros sur votre salaire
à la fin nous à
raymond vall et choisit ses abonnés
choisissez un représentant des matériaux
vraiment pas laisser partir ces mots
général pour salut d'été main attends je
vois pas
adhérent
attention
ça sent l'odeur
de zéro pourquoi on est aussi nul ne
sera pas
[Musique]
validé non mais c'est ce que voulait
changer non
continuerai mon là se trouve à l'échangé
changé
non mais ça compte pas il est nul
[Rires]
bien que l'on gagne
en forme on l'a on met phase i merci
quand on tend concentre-toi
sénat il est nul mais là plus de chance
on la remet aux larmes et pourquoi c'est
pas loin du ballon
et fautes 3 partout aulas croit pas aux
montées de gilles ouais ce que vous
voulez vous plaît est ce que vous voulez
doublé à 3 partout oui ouais pourquoi
oui oui ça veut dire vous deux vous
enlève 40e
vous gagné 206 nombre et 200 m si c'est
bon je le sens pour l'association alsace
il a été gêné là je commençais à me
faire chier
vous lisez mamba est belle ou à
l'exacerbation du lait chérie tu vas y
est vous êtes à 4-3 pour moi est ce que
vous voulez un joker c'est quoi notre
ère un joker il peut vous représentez ça
peut être un joker positif ou un joker
ouais négatif oui mais c'est très bien
que notre
attention c'est vrai qu'un joker négatif
non non après comme ça peut être un
joker possible
comprenez le joker oui m
prenez le joker sur
l'auto caire il rêve notre joker arrive
à
cette politique de rigueur stanislas
wawrinka
ces notations
l'exemple
sabrina est là
équipe référence
mais alors je t'explique mon style
abords d'un marché a été très bon comme
ça c'est du temps où bébé d'amour hier
c'est un de mes meilleurs amis à vous le
savez il est bonjour voila c'est un
triple vainqueur de grand chelem c'est
très simple pas cette année un paquet
cette année on n'en parle pas de cette
année cette année pour moi on était là
pour s'entraîner pour le us open vrai ou
pas c'est vrai mais c'est un beau
tournoi roland mais voilà il était oui
voilà les chéris il ne parlait pas au
chroniqueur il ne parlait pas vécu
son bon stan c'est très simple il ya
quatre ans pour moi sur le petit terrain
s'ils gagnent je le rajoute alors
maintenant qu'elle d'aucuns ont enlevé 1
100 euros d'accord chacun danse sinon
s'ils perdent je l'enlève 40 euros dans
leur salaire
sur ce petit terrain est ce que tu vas
marrant toi tu les représentent qu'eux
mais je vais permanents à temps
puisque tu peux m'adresser si tu gagnes
on compte sur toi ouais si tu gagnes
stan si tu gagnes ce stade il y aura
aussi je sais que tu as une association
qui tient à coeur c'est make a wish il y
aura un beau billet pour mes coaches
attention tu es parti alors on est à 4 3
pondre naturel on va les mettre en 8
parce qu'on les oublie ce cas 4 3 pour
kit pour moi elles on compte sur toi
voilà ça
[Applaudissements]
qu'ils aient besoin d'y aller si reed
est encore une gêne pas olalala classe
voilà tout en douce à des
sorties lefort
54.4
[Musique]
attention
c'était après
allez même pas
c'était facile mais ça ça me convient
ouais c'est toi tu viens à nos atouts
8,5
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est maintenant à cheveux pour
l'association c'est très simple regardez
il ya des trous ici dès le moment où tu
vas commencer et déjà prendre ta
raquette et à chaque fois il ya des
sommes c'est arrivé à mettre la balle
dans le trou tu gagneras la somme
indiquée auquel faire ça tout faire le
fai refuse et je me marie aké de tu te
verra c'est la première fois
changé diminution
massive et au centre toi d'être ici
m
j'viens fouet faites le à 3par croix
comme ça ça va plus il prenait une balle
chacun
toutes les bateaux je voulais dit mettez
vous la mettez vous là toutes les balles
chacun allait y aller et badiane mettez
vous l'attendez grammont top à mon top
non à mon top étoiles
c'est pas possible se régler
je suis avec des mines bon sens bien mon
sac bien via mons thalassa ne va vous
donner des conseils ah oui bah le devons
toujours pas le devant les mecs de
montréal devant stan stade pour toi qui
es le plus grand joueur de tous les
temps c'est que c'est une question
difficile ça parce que c'est nadal je
pense pas non parce que c'était des
rêves non plus est-ce que c'est djoko
sur djokovic ça pourrait mais je connais
le son c'est son cousin c'est qu'ils
sont cousins nos macs chocolat
c'est qu'on a fait tout seul c'est quand
tout cet égard de plus d'une heure pour
ça
chocolat